official 3D printed mock-ups of the
iPhone 15 lineup have been leaked online
and the big question is this should you
wait for the new iPhone 15 lineup with
this brand new redesign or is it
disappointing let's jump right into it
now these are the actual official iPhone
15 models and we know that for sure
because Max Weinbach almost a month ago
leaked the exclusive iPhone 15 Pro cads
and these are the case CAD so they are
official and he was actually right the
year before with the iPhone 14 pro cads
that turned out to be completely true
and then he even posted the official
iPhone 15 case cads which also seemed to
be correct based on the same design then
we also get the 15 Pro Max as well from
Ice Universe matching everything quite
well and based on those official cats
Ian's elbow has been working on some
realistic renders as you can see we have
a new titanium finish for the 15 Pro and
Promax models USBC and a new design
where it's not completely flat on the
bottom it curves into the display
matching the 2.5 D glass so that is
going to be absolutely amazing but
getting to the point of if it's
disappointing or not one thing that we
do know for sure is that the iPhone is
currently on a three-year redesigned
cycle where every three iPhones we get a
full redesign for example the iPhone 6
got a full redesign in 2014 with the
rounded curves and edges then we got the
iPhone 10 in 2017 three years later with
the notch a complete redesign with
stainless steel sides and so many other
changes then in 2020 we got the iPhone
12 with flat sides and other changes big
ones that came to it and then of course
this year the iPhone 15 lineup three
years later with that new design that
I'm going to show you and get into with
those 3D printed mock-ups and then three
years from now we're also getting the
iPhone 18 and as you can see right here
based on the rumors we're gonna have no
Notch no camera nothing three years from
now and maybe even bigger changes
potentially portless and you can see
Ross young was actually the leaker for
that here is his layout for the next
couple of years as you can see this
shows that both the iPhone 15 regular
models and Pro Models are getting the
pill plus hole finally getting rid of
the Notch and then apparently next year
they're putting face ID under the
display for the next couple of years and
then finally with the 2026 iPhone 18
three years from now everything is going
under the display and basically my
prediction for that model three years
from now is a completely portless iPhone
being the first iPhone to be fully
waterproof even in salt water and that's
because they're getting rid of all the
ports and switching to haptic buttons as
I'm going to show you in this video so
let's get in into these 3D mock-ups but
first I've got to show you the new Halo
lock Gia wallet stand from our partner
ESR it's actually the world's first
magsafe wallet with an apple certified
Bluetooth find by module built in which
means it can be tracked in real time
using the find my app including a
speaker to help you find it whereas
Apple's macsafe wallet only updates the
location when it's attached onto your
phone making it kind of useless the Geo
wallet stand comes with a built-in
battery that lasts 3 months as well as a
really cool USBC to pin charger so
there's no actual ports on the wallet
either it holds up to three cards with a
dynamic tension spring so they won't
fall out as well as a cutout at the
bottom to help get them out the max save
connection is very strong with a 1500 G
holding force over two times more than
Apple's wallet it also comes with a
convenient finger Loop and highly
adjustable stand built in which also
works in landscape mode for watching
videos so definitely check it out using
the link in the description below and
now let's get into the 3D mock-ups of
the iPhone 15 lineup and I do want to
mention that they did this last year as
well with the 14 series and those turned
out to be completely spot on and
accurate so we can trust and rely in
these mock-ups so let's get right into
it so we see the lineup of four phones
we have the iPhone 15 then the 15 plus
15 Pro and the 15 Pro Max exactly as we
have it right now we have basically the
same lineup now right off the bat we can
see the bottom of the iPhone 15 and we
can notice the USB type-c port so yes
the entire lineup is getting USBC but we
also notice the curved edges going
around the bottom side and all the sides
and merging with the glass so the glass
is actually going to be flat on the
display side but as it gets into the
bezels it's going to be etched with 2.5
D glass that merges into the actual
metal frame exactly how the Apple
watches are currently manufactured the
glass itself just merges perfectly into
the frame so that's being brought to the
iPhone 15 lineup whereas we have the
iPhone 14 pro Max right here and you can
see that we have sharp edges on the
sides right here so it's completely flat
with sharp edges flat on the front as
well so that's being completely changed
this year and now you're gonna feel like
you're holding it like it's very smooth
and it's also going to feel thinner
because those Corners are basically
getting shaved down and nice and smooth
and now moving on to the 15 plus we can
basically see that the camera bump is
staying fairly similar yes it's getting
a little bit larger but not by that much
and yes we still only have two cameras
no telephoto on the regular models which
is of course a little bit disappointing
and now we have the 15 Pro look at that
massive camera bump that we have it's
absolutely huge and then when he twist
it sideways look at how thick the camera
bump is getting with the 15 Pro Models
it's absolutely insane sticking out like
crazy almost the size of the phone
itself in the camera bump mind blowing
of course we see the USBC port and one
thing on the Pro Models is that it might
actually be a lot faster in terms of the
transfer speeds maybe even Thunderbolt
or USB 4 speeds which is going to be so
much faster than the regular models
which probably will be limited to USB
2.0 speeds just like we have on the
current iPhones right now insanely slow
but now check this out this is a very
important part because it shows a
massive change to the buttons as you can
see unlike on the regular models we have
one large button on the 15 Pro you can
actually see that difference right here
with the volume buttons on all of them
and there's some huge changes as you can
see on the bottom we have a regular
rocker for the silent switch or the MU
switch and then two separate volume
buttons up and down but this time around
it's getting completely revamped as you
can see at the top the Pro Models the
pro and the pro Max the actual mute
switch is getting changed and redesigned
with these couple of pins on the inside
that you can see now for the volume
button we have a huge long button
instead of individual ones right here
now this was actually mentioned and
reported on by Daniel from zone of tech
and other people chimed in basically
saying that we're getting solid state
unified buttons for the volume rocker
and the mute button instead of using a
switch so basically they are no longer
going to physically move or click at all
it's literally going to work like touch
ID the solid state button used to work
or in fact it still does work that way
on the iPhone SE model so essentially
it's going to be one long button and
it's going to feel when you press up or
down and it might even be able to be
switched to do different things into the
settings I'm not exactly sure but I am
sad to see the new Switch go and get
replaced with a mute button that is
going to suck now to show that these
were actually the case cads we can see
that they have new iPhone 15 cases and
everything's going to be changed around
so unfortunately you won't be able to
use your iPhone 14 pro or regular lineup
cases for these new models you're gonna
have to buy new ones but now let me go
back and answer the original question is
this going to be a disappointing
redesign this year well in my opinion no
I think it's actually going to be pretty
awesome first of all because we have
this new titanium finish which is going
to look and feel different it's actually
going to lower the weight of the iPhone
compared to the current model we have
now of course USBC is going to be an
absolute dream across the entire lineup
that is going to be amazing it's going
to improve your transfer speeds at least
on the Pro Models that's going to be
very helpful and it's going to make it
more convenient for the average user
just having USBC Chargers and cables and
accessories everywhere instead of having
to find your lightning cable that's
going to be awesome for example the iPad
Pros use usb-c Chargers so you can just
use the same charger for both of those
on top of that we also know that the
regular models are ditching the notch
for good finally so anybody buying the
regular models is going to have a better
experience better display without the
Notch and I've got to say personally I
like the idea of having flat sides on
the bottom but it being curved around
the actual edges and Corners to match up
with the glass so it is going to feel
much better in your hand compared to
having the sharp edges of the iPhone 14
kind of dig into your hands so it's
going to feel Slimmer and better overall
all more premium so even though we
didn't get a massive redesign like these
renders that I created with renders by
Shailesh showing a completely flat back
with an extra camera the telephoto
basically the telescopic one it looks
like Apple's gonna basically combine the
telescopic camera into the telephoto
completely replacing it and hopefully
having automatic Zoom like real Zoom
built into the iPhone from 3x to 6X so
none of this is happening we're not
getting massive changes like this but I
do think the redesign that we are
getting is going to be good enough so
with that said if you disagree with me
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed this video
click the circle about to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign